health authorities in india say the
country has now exceeded
4 million coronavirus cases nearly
2 million new infections were recorded
last month alone
india has the third highest total
worldwide behind the u.s and brazil
even so restrictions in india have been
eased as the government pushes to
reopen the economy only the worst hit
areas are still
under lockdown
for more we're joined now by dw
correspondent namisha jaiswal who's in
delhi hello to you namisha so
a grim milestone four million infections
in
india as we said it's the third highest
national total in the world but closing
in on brazil
and yet we're hearing that lockdown
restrictions are being lifted
do most people in the country support
this government policy
well mariana it is safe to say yes
actually
because if you step out in cities like
new delhi and bombay
you will see crowds out and about that
no in no way indicate
numbers of 4 million infections of a
highly infectious disease
lockdown restrictions have almost
completely been lifted
yes some high of high density places are
still not open
but most shops markets gyms
are back in track even schools and
colleges there are plans to start
reopening them
by the end of the month the people seem
to agree with the government's belief
that
india must learn to live with the
coronavirus the economic slowdown caused
by the lockdown
cannot be afforded so there is perhaps a
lockdown fatigue that is encouraging
people to come out and say
this is life now we have to move on
well as the restrictions are being eased
we know
as you mentioned you know students are
going back to the university
and hundreds of thousands of students
are also being told to go ahead with
their exams
but how safe can that be you did send us
a report let's have a look
examinations during a pandemic
schools and colleges remain closed as
india records the highest daily rise in
cases in the world
these students are appearing for a
crucial test
and it's testing like never before masks
assigned at the exam center
constant sanitization and repeated calls
for social distancing
parents and students here are reassured
by these measures
they say they cannot afford to lose any
more time to the pandemic
all the candidates are trying hard to
give this exam but yeah it was okay
because as all the safety measures were
taken so that it was okay
to give the exam during the pandemic
they could have conducted this exam in
april the case load was low then
but they pushed it to july and now this
they can't afford any more delays
yet not everyone has been this
enthusiastic about the tests
many of the competitive exams held every
year in india have faced stiff
opposition this time
students have protested online against
the risks they say they are being forced
to take
and have even approached the supreme
court students took to social media to
trend the hashtag rise against exams in
kovid
while the supreme court has rejected
their demands students say forcing them
to appear for the exams is cruel
pavli agarwal an aspiring doctor
is expected to travel 150 kilometers
next week to her test center
she hasn't stepped out in five months
and is terrified to do so
she heard rumors over social media that
another exam led to dozens of kobit 19
i deaths many students whose parents are
asking them to skip exams this year
it is far too risky to go for them
nothing is decided for me either
my family is scared they don't know
whether i should go for this exam or not
opposition parties have taken up the
cause as well
they accused the modi government of
being anti-student
protesters insist they don't want the
exams cancelled
but simply postponed until it is safer
we are sharing the concern of the
students of the entire country
and their parents because
opposition state government already
given a request to the
prime minister of india to postpone this
examination for time being these
students however
intend to get on with their plans they
say
their careers will have to be formed
within this new normal
all right namisha as you reported it
seems like a lot of students want to get
on with their exams and get on with
their lives
and others are more cautious but do you
feel that
most students do just want to get on
with it what do the majority of students
think
well mariana it's difficult to place a
clear majority in either camp because on
the one hand you have hundreds of
thousands of students turning out
every day to take these exams including
today
over a fortnight over two million people
over two million aspirants i expect to
appear for these exams
and we saw students and parents saying
we've already almost wasted a semester
we do not want to waste an academic year
let's just go on ahead but on the other
hand we cannot deny that there have been
massive online products
that the opposition has taken up this
cry as well in fact just
yesterday the supreme court of india
shot down an opposition request
to postpone these exams but perhaps
students and parents are falling in line
with the general sentiment
that this is life now and we must
continue operating
despite the pandemic well one glimmer of
hope perhaps is that despite the
alarming rise in infections
the fatality rate in fact remains
rather low it's about two percent do we
know why that is
well there are theories mariana no
definitive proof yet but one factor that
experts seem to be citing
is that india does have a younger
population than many of the developed
countries that have not done
as well and that in senior age groups
india is actually comparable the
fatality rate is comparable
to the countries which suffered more we
also have theories about what is called
cross
reactivity basically countries like
india have high exposure to other
coronaviruses
which may actually help people fight off
this strain of coronavirus
better but of course further studies are
required to truly find
out what is the reason behind the
facility rate also critics say that the
fetality rate may be underestimated
in case there is under counting of
deaths namisha jaiswal reporting for us
from delhi many thanks indeed